torches illuminated the center of buenos
aires on wednesday
they were carried by nurses from
argentina's capital
to demand better salaries
lorenadilla says public health care
workers are exhausted
and underpaid
in my hospital there are covered
patients on every floor
we have friends that got sick our salary
leaves us below the poverty line
we have to work in several hospitals to
make ends meet
healthcare workers are also victims of
the economic crisis in argentina
that's been exacerbated by the pandemic
purchasing power has been weakened by
the double-digit inflation rate that's
been haunting argentina for years
but in this hospital in moreno outside
the capital
the situation is even worse nurses say
they haven't been paid in six months
hospitals and health centers
like this one in argentina have been
struggling to cope with the rise of
covet-19
infections doctors and nurses say that
they've been working
non-stop since the pandemic began and
that they were summoned by the
government to deal
with a national emergency until now
they've never been paid
they're desperate and that's why they
started protesting
outside the hospital all of us continue
to work
even though we are not paid we all work
with covet patients we like basic items
like syringes
but we are here trying to care for our
patients
we don't know when we are going to get
paid there's about 120 people
in a similar situation at the hospital
some of them
are about to be evicted from their homes
because they're unable to pay rent
labor unions are distributing food to
those struggling to make ends meet
most of the ones working here are women
and we are vulnerable over how we are
treated
we are helping patients but also our
families
and we do all this without a salary many
are afraid to speak
out because they are afraid to lose
their jobs even though they're not paid
argentina is battling an economic crisis
and a pandemic
that has left more than 10 000 people
dead in the past month
the government has shut down schools and
imposed a curfew to contain the spread
of infections
but for more than a year hospital
workers have provided the front line
against covet 19
and they say that if they are to carry
on effectively
they need better wages
perishable al jazeera buenos aires